all the children
have to have their own life obviously
Priscilla Presley is famously mom to
Lisa Marie Presley her daughter with
Elvis but she's also got a son nearly a
decade after Priscilla's divorce from
Elvis the actress had a baby boy
Navarone Garibaldi Garcia so what's
there to know about Priscilla's only son
Navarone was born in 1987. his father is
TV producer Marco Garibaldi Priscilla's
then partner but his upbringing wasn't
exactly what you'd think in an interview
with people he says quote there's a
misconception that I was raised
extravagantly with Elvis's estate and
money that wasn't the case and as a kid
Navarone tried his best to stay out of
the spotlight quote I got in trouble
more than everybody else because kids
parents would find out who my mom was
and they'd want a reason to talk to her
I wasn't very comfortable with it we
have to respect the kids during
navarone's teenage years he says he
became addicted to heroin and Fentanyl
and when he turned 18 he left Los
Angeles and moved to Santa Cruz for a
clean start while living there his
parents 20-year long relationship came
to an end which meant Priscilla started
playing Elvis Tunes around the house
again
[Music]
[Applause]
Navarone explains quote I think my dad
had a bit of a complex about Elvis's
music it wasn't until after he left that
my mom started playing his music again
freely we really tried to celebrate
Elvis's life and like Elvis Navarone
caught the music bug by 2012 he was back
in La pursuing a career with his rock
band them guns
[Music]
he says I thought okay I'm going into
the family business I'll write a song
and then we'll start touring it I didn't
realize it takes way more than that it
is huge you know to live under
under the the light of someone as big as
Elvis it's a big responsibility as for
navarone's personal life he's married
his then-girlfriend Alyssa accepted his
proposal in late 2020 and the two tied
the knot in Switzerland just over a year
later fast forward to 2023 and tragedy
struck when Lisa Marie died unexpectedly
after suffering cardiac arrest
thank you for being here
and the family of course and all of you
our heart is broken Lisa we all love you
and while Navarone wasn't close to his
half-sister in the Years leading up to
her death he did attend her Memorial at
Graceland and remembered her on
Instagram quote I know the past couple
years weren't easy for you and I wish
things had been different between us
regardless you are my sister and I'm
sending love and prayers for your
journey home now she is home where she
always belong but my heart is missing
her love but amid the family's tragedy
Navarone is moving forward
professionally his band is releasing a
new track and he's hoping to go on tour
with them soon quote a lot of people
know about me but they don't know me
there were some points where I didn't
think I'd make it here I'm so proud of
how far I've come
foreign